Google cloud next 2017 hosted a
veritable smorgasbord of talks detailing
the future of cloud if you didn't get a
chance to catch bigquery and cloud
machine learning advancing large-scale
neural network predictions then stay
tuned because here is the recap one of
the common challenges with using machine
learning is storing processing and
supplying huge volumes of training data
to your ml engine thankfully Google
cloud platform makes this super easy
with the combination of bigquery a
petabyte scale enterprise data warehouse
and cloud ml engine which is a fully
managed tensorflow
platform used together bigquery can
supply huge volumes of training data to
ml engine which can create training and
prediction models which can be
distributed and used on various
platforms
the most common use case for combining
bigquery and ml engine is to use
bigquery as a data Lake you can store
all the data you're interested in even
if you're not using it all and pre
process various parts of it before
exporting it to tensorflow
or ml engine you can then use your
trained models to enable more advanced
queries of your company data now it's
really common to run searches on your
data using keyword matching which is
specifying tags you can use to find
content such as the actor's name the
movie name or the music type anything
you can find in the document or its
metadata while useful tag based searches
are not as powerful as using feature
vectors which are a list of tuples
containing words and they're important
score relative to the west of the words
in the document
and since bigquery lets you create
user-defined functions within SQL
queries we can write JavaScript
functions that calculate the feature
vector for each document and determines
how similar they are to each other you
could use this technique to find similar
questions on Stack Overflow or similar
posts on reddit you can use the same
approach for all content not just
documents and that's where ml engine
comes into play we can create ML models
to extract feature vectors from
unstructured data like images natural
language or spending patterns and then
use big queries UDF to do feature vector
queries using those models when applied
to images instead of getting a list of
labels describing the content of each
picture we get feature vectors that can
be compared
to those from other images as a result
even without knowing what's in each
image we can search bigquery for similar
images or perform analysis based on
grouping those similar images another
use case for combining bigquery and
machine learning is to perform
large-scale demand forecasting and
providing recommendations for your
customers
we're once again going to take advantage
of big queries user-defined functions
this time we'll use historical buying
trends to train models using the ML
engine those trends can be based on
variables including the months the
season or even the weather or you can
use the buying trends of groups of users
to predict what products you should be
recommending them once you've developed
the models you can store them in cloud
storage and make forecasts and
predictions for specified conditions
being passed as inputs to user-defined
functions within bigquery to understand
more about feature vectors and see a
bunch of examples of how to use ml
engine and bigquery together
check out Casas full session video for
all the details and if you want more
recaps on great next content make sure
to check out the rest of our playlist
and don't forget the next world tour
coming soon to a city near you
[Music]
you